[goat bleats]
- THAT'S GOOD, GARY.
START IT OUT, BROTHER.
GOT TO GET YOU FIT, MATE.
THAT'S GOOD, GARY.
NOT IN FRONT OF THE CAR.
I DON'T WANT TO RUN YOU OVER.
THAT'S GOOD, GARY!
[laughter]
- I'LL HAVE THE SAME THING!
- [laughs]
- OH!
HE'S HORNY.
WE'RE GONNA CHECK ROEY
OVER HERE
WHO'S PUTTING A BUCK 35
OF COINS
UP HIS FORESKIN.
HE'S GONNA SPIT IT OUT, OKAY?
GARY'S HAVING A LOOK AT HIM.
- DO IT! DO IT! DO IT!
- [laughs]
WOW!
- HOW MUCH WAS THAT?
- $1.35.
- WHAT HAPPENED TO $1.40?
- HEY, GIRLS, DO YOU WANT
TO STICK A BUCK 40
UP YOUR [bleep]
TO BEAT HIM?
[laughter]
GARY, WHERE ARE YOU, MATE?
MATE--
I DON'T REALLY WANT TO KNOW.
- YOU CAN HAVE
YOUR HUGH JACKMANS
AND YOUR CROCODILE DUNDEES,
BUT FOR MY MONEY,
THERE'S NO BIGGER CELEBRITY
IN AUSTRALIA
THAN GARY THE GOAT.
GARY...
AND HIS OWNER JIMBO
HAVE MADE HUNDREDS OF VIDEOS,
BUT THEY'VE NEVER DONE
AN INTERVIEW,
AND I'VE NEVER TALKED
TO A GOAT BEFORE,
SO PLEASE WELCOME
THE GREATEST GOAT OF ALL TIME,
GARY!
- GOOD DAY FROM AUSTRALIA.
- WHERE DID YOU AND GARY MEET?
- I DO COMEDY SHOWS
IN PUBS,
AND AFTER A GIG,
A GUY OFFERED ME A GOAT
FOR A CASE OF BEER.
- I GOT TO START PERFORMING
IN AUSTRALIA.
MY FANS HERE JUST GIVE ME DRUGS
AND PUSSY AFTER SHOWS.
CAN GARY DO ANY TRICKS?
- NO, HE DOESN'T PLAY GUITAR
OR SING OR JUGGLE
OR ANYTHING.
HE JUST GOES INTO THE PUBS.
HE WALKS AROUND,
STEALS PEOPLE'S CHIPS,
DOES A [bleep],
AND FALLS ASLEEP.
- YOU AND GARY
MIGHT BE ALCOHOLICS.
- GARY DOESN'T DRINK,
WHICH I'M REALLY HAPPY,
BECAUSE EVERY NIGHT
PEOPLE ARE OFFERING HIM BEER,
AND IF THAT--
IF GARY DRANK,
I'D HAVE A DRUNK GOAT
EVERY NIGHT,
AND THAT'S NOT GOOD
'CAUSE HE SOMETIMES
HAS GOT TO DRIVE HOME.
- DOES GARY LET YOU
RIDE HIM HOME?
- NO, BUT I'VE GOT A GOAT BUGGY
ON THE BACK.
I'VE GOT A--LIKE, A HARNESS
FOR A HORSE,
WHERE I'VE SAT IN THE BACK,
AND, YEAH,
BUT WE COULDN'T STEER,
SO WE JUST RAN INTO A TRUCK.
- HEY, ARE THERE ANY
LITTLE GARYS IN THE FUTURE?
- NO, NO,
HE'S GOT NO BALLS,
WHICH MEANS
GARY'S THE END OF THE LINE.
THAT'S WHY HE'S GOING HARD.
- WELL, WE APPRECIATE HIM
GOING HARD.
THANKS FOR BEING HERE, GARY.
- BYE-BYE.
- WE'VE GOT A GARY
IN OUR OFFICE,
AND HE IS THE LIFE
OF THE PARTY TOO.
GARY.
- WHAT THEY COULD DO
ON A WINTER DAY
IS PUT THE TREADMILL OUTSIDE
AND TAKE SWEET POTATOES
THAT HAVE JUST BEEN BAKED...
- OH, OKAY.
- AND PUT 'EM IN THE CROTCH
OF YOUR PANTS.
- GARY!
- AND AS YOU'RE WALKING--
AS YOU'RE WALKING
ON THE TREADMILL,
THE SWEET POTATOES GET MUSHY,
AND THEY'RE STILL WARM,
AND THEY START RUNNING DOWN
THE INSIDE OF YOUR LEGS,
AND IT MAKES YOU FEEL LIKE
YOU'RE IN ANOTHER PART
OF THE COUNTRY,
AND YOU DON'T KNOW WHERE YOU ARE
OR HOW YOU GOT THERE,
BUT IT FEELS GOOD.
YOU HAVE A DIMENSIONAL OUTTAKE
OF WHAT YOUR REALISTICS ARE.
YOU LIVE IN AN INVISIBLE PRISON.
YOU DON'T KNOW YOU'RE LOCKED UP,
BUT YOUR MIND DOES.
[laughing obnoxiously]
- GARY!
- I HAVEN'T EVEN STARTED YET!
- OH, GOD.
- I'VE HAD A COUPLE
OUT-OF-BODY EXPERIENCES.
HA!
YOU GUYS DRINK A LOT HERE?
AND A CARLOAD OF DOGS PULLED UP
IN FRONT OF MY HOUSE
ABOUT FIVE YEARS AGO.
- GARY.
[laughs]
GARY!
- [clears throat]
IT'S CALLED LUBRICANT LAND.
IT WOULD BE A HALFWAY
AMERICAN FLAG.
DON'T GIVE UP!
- GARY.
- YOU COULD PAINT A HERD
OF HUMMINGBIRDS IN FORMATION
FLYING THIS WAY TO HIM
LIKE A "V."
EEE!
DICK OF THE WEEK.
- GARY!
- OH, HOW ABOUT A LITTLE HEAD?
[laughter]
THOSE MINIATURE GOATS,
I'VE SEEN 'EM FORNICATE
WITH MAILBOX POSTS.
THEY JUST GET UP THERE
AND HUMP IT.
- PEEN.
- GARY.
- TRY TO EXPLORE THAT WORD
A LITTLE DEEPER WITH ME.
- PEEN, PEEN.
- PEEN.
- ARE YOU THINKING OF "BEAN"?
- PEEN?
- PEEN.
PEEN.
[laughter]
I'M GLAD YOU'RE NOT A TEACHER,
MAN.
- OH, IF YOU--
- IF YOU HAVE A HARD TIME
ABOUT--
OH!
HE LEFT.
HE'S TALKING ABOUT YOUR PENIS.
[laughter]
- LIKE A FINE WINE,
GARY BUSEY ONLY IMPROVES
WITH AGE.
HE IS THE HEART AND SOUL
OF THIS SHOW.
HE'S INSANE--
INSANELY TALENTED!
GARY ASKED IF HE COULD COME BACK
ON ANOTHER EPISODE
AND PHYSICALLY BATTLE ME
WITH CHILDREN'S TOYS.
I HAVE NO IDEA WHAT THAT MEANS,
BUT I SAID YES.